bien le bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je
vais venir vous aider concernant la
batterie et l'autonomie de votre
smartphone
oui parce que souvent avec ces petites
bêtes là on a des déconvenues ours et
pas forcément comment bien le chargé on
n'a pas forcément toujours les bonnes
astuces les bonnes clés et il ya plein
de rumeurs et souvent des fausses
rumeurs qui circulent sur internet et on
ne sait pas réellement quoi faire pour
savoir bien chargé son smartphone alors
vous aurez remarqué aujourd'hui on
change de trois trucs ont laissé un set
up un petit peu différent regarder ça la
regarde et moi je voulais simplement une
radio salut à 12 à l'humanisme ouzou
creux en mode un peu podcast parce que
oui dans quelques temps il ya le podcast
qui va arriver ça c'est une autre
histoire je vous en reparlerai vous
invite donc à vous abonner dès
maintenant comme ça vous saurez tout et
si vous ne connaissez pas la chaîne et
si vous la découvrirez actuellement à
gaza chez que je vous présente tous les
nouveaux smartphones je vous parle de
smartphones mais pas que smartphone ya
aussi des montres connectés il ya des
tablettes des ordinateurs ya pas mal de
choses et puis je donne plein d'astuces
comme aujourd'hui pour savoir comment
bien charger votre smartphone dans les
meilleures conditions alors aujourd'hui
il y aura cette astuce s'est passé
encore défaut bonjour mes trucs durera
cette astuce et à la fin je partagerai
trois ou quatre bonus de ces mots garder
à la fin je partage 5 bonus pour vous
dire exactement comment charger votre
smartphone dans les meilleures
conditions vous allez voir au final
c'est pas très compliqué la toute
première astuce c'est de ne pas laisser
décharger complètement votre smartphone
je sais qu'il existe beaucoup de rumeurs
qui vont dire tout et n'importe quoi
croyez moi ne laissait pas décharger
votre smartphone à 100% alors si ce
délai charge à 100% c'est pas grave il
va pas mourir pour autant mais il faut
éviter de prendre cette habitude qui
somme toute une mauvaise habitude il
faut penser à recharger son smartphone
bien plus régulièrement ça je vous
l'expliquais dans quelques instants
le deuxième point c'est son contraire ne
chargez pas votre smartphone à 100% il
faut savoir que les charges complètes
sont pas bonnes pour votre smartphone ça
crée un stress pour votre batterie et
c'est pas idéal
la meilleure façon de charger votre
smartphone c'est de le recharger
régulièrement contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire il ne faut pas le
décharger à fond donc le mettre à 0% et
leur montée à 100% en lui mettant des
grands cycles c'était vrai pour les
batteries beaucoup plus ancienne mais
pour les smartphones récents
ça ne sert absolument à rien nous
vraiment je vous le déconseille
fortement penser à recharger votre
smartphone lorsqu'ils arrivent aux
alentours de 30% s'il arrive à 20% est
absolument aucun problème vous le
charger vous le faites remonter pour le
remonter jusqu'à 80% et le débranche
heures ce que vous en avez besoin c'est
beaucoup mieux d'avoir plusieurs
recharge dans la journée lorsque vous
besoin plutôt que de monter à 100% le
descendre à 0 % le seul moment où vous
pourriez venir lui mettre des grandes
charge complète c'est si votre batterie
arrive à l'ordre de 30% et vos
smartphones c'est un ça semble vouloir
dire en tout cas que votre batterie ya
un problème avant de la changer
ce que je vous conseille à ce moment là
c'est de la recharge est à 100% vous la
vider complètement voulu fait deux trois
cycles et vous verrez ça résout le
problème si ça ce n'est pas le problème
à ce moment là il faudra changer la
batterie de votre smartphone d'ailleurs
penser plutôt à changer la batterie de
votre smartphone que de changer votre
smartphone tout de suite c'est moins
cher d'une pour vous et c'est bien mieux
pour la planète
on parlait une époque de mémoire de
batterie c'est pas vrai sur les
batteries au lithium que vous y
retrouver dans votre smartphone donc ne
vous en mettez pas penser vraiment à
venir le charger lorsque vous êtes lors
de 30% remontée lui un peu et au fur et
à mesure de la journée en fonction de
vos besoins des déplacements un peu
longue si vous allez pouvoir le charger
ou pas à ce moment-là voulu mettre un
peu de charges
mieux vaut le faire plusieurs fois dans
la journée que faire des grands cycles
le troisième point et pas des moindres
il faut savoir que les smartphones et
notamment les batteries n'aime
absolument pas les températures extrêmes
ne leur charge et pas lorsqu'il est en
plein soleil lorsque vous êtes sur une
terrasse en train de siroter votre
cocktail au bord de votre piscine ou je
ne sais où dans l'herbe ne le branchait
pas à ce moment là lorsque votre
smartphone est en plein soleil c'est
très mauvais pour votre batterie de la
même manière en hiver ne changez pas vos
smartphones alors qu'ils arrêtent d'une
température extérieure à - 0 degré les
saleuses sera chauffée tranquillement et
lorsque vous le touchez et qu'il vous
semble être à température ambiante et
bien à ce moment là vous le branchez
vous le charger ça sera beaucoup mieux
pour lui vous pouvez charger
températures entre 0° à 45 degrés oui
vous avez quand même de quoi faire c'est
vraiment large comme fourchette de même
il ya une vieille rumeur qui existaient
qui disait qu'il fallait mettre sa
batterie au congélateur avant de la
charge et elle ne fait absolument pas ça
je n'ai pas du tout oumy quatrième
astuces n'utilisait pas de chargeur non
prévus pour votre smartphone pas que
vous ne puissiez passer dans le commerce
des chargeurs adapté à votre smartphone
vous pourriez en trouver mais si vous
utilisez un chargeur rapide par exemple
si vous prenez un smartphone standard
qui n'accepte pas la recharge rapide ou
qui acceptent de la recharge rapide 18
watts ou vingt et quelques watts
n'allez pas utiliser un chargeur 65
watts sans quoi vous allez endommager
votre batterie et ça serait con ce que
je vous conseille c'est de n'utiliser
que des chargeurs prévu par votre
constructeur ou des chargeurs homologué
pour votre smartphone n'avait pas
m'acheter des chargeurs
quelques euros qui traînerait sur amazon
de mauvaise qualité mieux vaut mettre un
peu plus d'argent assurer la longévité
de sa batterie et la sécurité de sa
maison sa part être une option bien
meilleure cinquième point et non des
moindres je sais pas si vous le faites
mais moi j'ai été pendant très longtemps
ne laissez pas charger votre smartphone
toute la nuit d'ailleurs dit moi tout de
suite en commentaire est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous faites que vous
faisiez est ce que vous saviez qu'il ne
fallait pas laisser son smartphone
branché toute la nuit c'est une habitude
qu'on a tous on se couche le soir il a
plu beaucoup de batterie on le branche
le lendemain matin on se lève la gueule
enfarinée on le prend on le débranche et
on est parti pour la journée alors
effectivement c'est pratique parce que
c'est complètement transparent pour nous
mais ce n'est pas du tout bon pour la
batterie de votre smartphone votre
smartphone aujourd'hui il va se
recharger en moins de deux heures ça
dépend bien évidemment du type de
chargeur et du smartphone que vous avez
aimé votre smartphone
lorsque vous allez laisser sept ou huit
heures chargées en continu et bien un
moment votre smartphone saura qu'il est
chargé il va arrêter de charger la
batterie mais lui va consommer
légèrement y va consommer est parti il
va se recharger en permanence et ça
c'est pas du tout bon pour la batterie
de votre smartphone
ça crée un stress s'émouvait à oublier à
proscrire
vous ne le fait plus vous oubliez
complètement sixième point sixième point
sixième point et non des moindres
lorsque votre smartphone se charge il va
venir chauffer davantage ce que je vous
conseille de faire puisque les
smartphones
j'ai pu faire tomber ce que je vous
conseille de faire puisque les
smartphones même absolument pas les
températures extrêmes c'est de venir
enlever la coque de votre smartphone
pour permettre à ce que la chaleur se
dissipe vous ayez donc une meilleure
répartition de la chaleur et vous
n'auriez pas une zone encore plus chaude
ou de votre smartphone puisque la
chaleur est accumulée et que votre
batterie n'aime pas sa septième point si
votre cab est endommagée racheter un
câble chez le constructeur de
smartphones ou auprès d'un vendeur que
vous connaissez avec des produits de
bonne qualité
de la même manière que pour votre blog
de charges vous n'allez pas l'acheter
n'importe où puisque vous n'êtes pas sur
la qualité du produit fait la même chose
avec votre câble pour pourrait se dire
ok un câble s'est jamais qu'un cas mais
croyez moi les finitions sont pas les
mêmes les soudures sont pas les mêmes et
pour la longévité de votre produit pour
la sécurité de votre maison
c'est important d'avoir des accessoires
qui sont vraiment de bonne qualité donc
voilà pour les sept points maintenant on
va se garder quelques bonus veuillez
réserver quelques en plus le premier
c'est une rumeur urbaine je sais pas si
vous la connaissez d'ailleurs je compte
sur vous pour me dire en bas on
commentaires qui consistait à dire que
lorsque vous achetiez votre smartphone
vous deviez absolument le charger à 100%
avant même de lui
utilisez sais pas si vous connaissez ce
point là et si vous le faisiez
d'ailleurs marqué le mois en bas en
commentaire alors autant ça pouvait être
vrai pour des anciennes générations de
batteries pour bonne technologie ok mais
pour les smartphones actuels vous
oublier complètement vous ne faites pas
une fois de plus ça va créer un stress
est pas bon quand vous prenez votre
smartphone vous l'ouvrez vous pouvez
l'utiliser et de la même année air lui
met des petites recharge régulière vous
avez pas besoin de le décharger à fond
de leurs charges et à fond c'est faux et
il faut pas le faire les deuxièmes
astuces et la charge idéal pour moi la
zone dans laquelle doit rester votre
batterie c'est entre hal et grosso modo
30 à 80% vous n'avez pas besoin de le
charger à fond ça je voulais dit ça sert
à rien le faire tomber trop bas quand
vous arrivez entre 30 à 40 %
vous pouvez leur charge et le monte un
peu jusqu'à 80% à peu près vous êtes
tranquilles tout ira bien et ça ne
donnera pas à la durée de vie de votre
batterie
une autre astuce que je vous conseille
puisque vous n'allez pas rechargez votre
smartphone durant toute la nuit dans la
mesure vous à nos smartphones qui a un
chargeur rapide ce que vous faites le
matin c'est que lorsque vous vous levez
vous le branchez vous prenez votre
douche vous déjeunez vous faites tout ce
que vous voulez ensuite vous le prenez
vous le débrancher spgo smartphones s'en
charger à 60 81% très rapidement et ça
c'est plutôt pratique
voilà très bon point voulait sa jolie
pouces c'est pour moi c'est cadeau un
autre point lorsque vous n'utilisez plus
votre chargeur pout on le laisser
brancher à une prise murale
est-ce que c'est dangereux est ce que
ces problématiques est ce qu'il faut le
faire oui ou non
alors je vous dirais que dans l'idéal
non juste pour une question
d'environnement parce que ça va toujours
consommé un tout petit peu d'énergie
un tout petit peu ça va représenter
quelques euros sur l'année néanmoins ce
qui est pris est pris
je vous déconseille de le laisser
brancher juste pour ce point là après en
terme de sécurité
vous n'avez rien à craindre à moins que
vous ayez un chien ou un animal de
compagnie qui viennent le grignoter
auquel cas ça pourrait être relativement
bas l'eau à moins que vous ayez un dégât
des eaux et que le niveau d'eau monte là
où vous aviez votre câble
mise à part ces quelques pour l'âge
voilà vous n'avez globalement rien à
craindre
c'est pas dangereux il ne va pas prendre
feu dans la mesure où vous avez un
chargeur et un câble de bonne qualité
dernier point et non des moindres vous
changer de smartphone mais vous gardez
l'ancien vous n'allez pas leur vendre
vous n'allez pas le donner pour
l'instant vous gardez vous allez le
maître précieusement dans une jolie
petite boîte en vous disant qu'un jour
si votre nouveau smartphone vous lâche
ou si vous avez un problème avec et bien
au moins vous aurez quand même un
appareil de secours ça peut sommes
toutes être assez logique d'ailleurs dit
moi si ça vous est déjà arrivé ce que je
vous conseille c'est de recharger au
moins
jusqu'à 40% vous l'éteignez vous mettez
dans la boîte et tout ira bien puisque
la batterie d'un smartphones même
éteints va continuer à se vider en
laissant 40% vous êtes tranquilles
pendant longtemps et ça ça ira plutôt
bien si toutes ces informations vous
intéressez vous invite bien évidemment à
vous abonner puis a regardé la vidéo
suivante on va continuer à parler de
bonne pratique de bonnes astuces de
tutos de bonnes informations je vous
présente et plein de nouveaux
smartphones donc ça c'est vachement bien
si vous voulez en savoir plus je vous
donne rien tout de suite je vous invite
à aller visiter le site www.ventos.lu
avec un y university avec un y
on est toujours en anglais point com qui
vous donnera toutes les informations
pour l'utilisation la longévité tout
savoir sur la batterie du smartphone et
les batteries des ordinateurs c'est un
site écrit uniquement en anglais donc si
vous ne parlez pas anglais toujours
utiliser google traduction
voilà parfois ça marche parfois ça
marche pas j'espère que cette vidéo vous
aura intéressé
si vous avez des questions ou
interrogations suggestions et des
astuces que vous vous connaissez je
n'aurais pas abordés vous pouvez les
marques et bien évidemment en bas en
commentaire sur ce je vous fais des gros
bisous des gros becs - et puis dites moi
si un format comme ça avec mon nouveau
joli petit micro ça vous intéresse
oui ou non on se joue en brasse vous
envoie blanc-bec beaucoup d'amour et à
très très vite
des bisous et câlins
[Musique]